check no just saying that their battle
continues they're going to continue to
technologically innovative but it's it's
hard to imagine what this service can be
if it's not what it's tried to be which
is essentially setting up a little
individual antennas to pick up the
on-air broadcasts and then route those
through the internet the court has found
that that's a copyright infringement
focusing on the copyright law not the
FCC responsibilities of broadcasters to
broadcast free over the air waves so an
interesting decision from the court and
sheds comments about check notion of the
CEO vario commenting about this I
thought one of the most interesting
things he said Justice Scalia gets this
right he says a quoting Justice Scalia
is saying that this decision has built
any shaky 'used of grounds he goes on to
talk also about the implications for
other computing business cloud computing
is very much imperiled by this decision
even though the majority said that it
shouldn't be that just because this
president has been said about copyright
the idea that you can mirror things and
copy things and have things exist in the
cloud could be challenged as a function
of this decision today and and that is
the most perhaps the most important part
of this ruling the immediate impact is
on Ariel and of course the broadcasters
who took area all right at the Supreme
Court Cory but you know what what what
Scalia and well what Scalia is saying is
that the six justices who ruled on Aereo
ruled at least in the broadcaster's
favor tried to fire a sniper's bullet
and what they may have instead done has
just thrown a cluster bomb into the
Internet I would have gone with
cannonball but sure uh you know is
summertime people at the pool but I look
I think the implications here could be
really serious and that this could be
cited in other cases that about sort of
copyright infringement copying things
imagine for example a music file right
we've seen a lot of copyright battles
take place we've got copies of it
residing in multiple servers so someone
can access it wherever they are or
wherever they're traveling does that
reflect a copyright infringement what
does it mean for for software and data
that's copied over and over again in
multiple servers who provide redundancy
is that a violation of copyright law
should users that work on the cloud have
to pay for multiple copies of something
to exist as opposed to single copies
those things are all open questions out
with this decision as you mentioned you
tries to be surgical and its logic but
it could have of course like all Supreme
Court decisions broad implications so
Cory was this case really San Francisco
vs LA tech vs. the entertainment
industry yeah you know I don't know I
mean I III I personally found that the
argument that the broadcaster's were
given their broadcast licenses have
built a business's worth billions of
dollars because of the exclusivity of
those of those licenses and and the
notion that they didn't want to share
those anymore than are claiming
copyright protection is is a challenging
one but the court didn't seem to really
care about that whatsoever they really
did focus on the implications of
copyright law and what that meant for
these decisions and I don't know if
that's really about you know you know
Northern California versus Southern
California or I think it's much more
about sort of the possibilities of I
don't think Aereo's business model is
about the possibility of Technology
Willy I think it really was as a Scalia
wrote really about a loophole and
finding a loophole and trying to exploit
a business around that but the
implications are much greater well the
question now for Ariel and for checkin
ogia and ultimately for Barry Diller and
I AC is what's left of that business
model in his statement Cory kanojo says
we're disappointed in the outcome but
our work is not done we will continue to
fight for our consumers and fight to
create innovative technologies that have
a meaningful and positive impact on our
world you might say what else could he
say but it does leave me wondering what
checking on you might get up to with the
remnants of what Aereo has
technologically or something else for
that matter you know this is the
smoldering ruins of area look I think
when he says our work is not done it's
like when people say I'm not in it for
the money what it means is his work is
done and they are in it for the money
that there's no business here left with
it they can't I can't possibly imagine
you know this business was about
exploiting a single loop hole with a
single single technological challenge or
a single technological solution to that
loophole I mean it was it was bordered
on the silly right as a creating little
paper clip size antennas to pick up a
radio signal and then put it online
it wasn't really solving a technological
problem as much as finding a way around
a rule and a law that now is being sort
of enforced it to a higher level all
right then if the fork is in and there's
nothing left for chut to do there what
else could he do among the power players
in the tech scene in Silicon Valley
where could we see Chet well it's a
great question you know he's a super
smart guy and and really seems to
understand how these businesses work and
how media businesses work and I would
imagine that you know we for example
today we expect Google to announce some
sort of set-top box or something of that
sort we have we've heard for a long time
that Apple's working on a TV thing
there's lots of innovation it could
happen around the way that we receive
television the way that tomorrow the
digital stuff is recorded and so on and
manipulated and there's certainly lots
of room for innovation there and if
ariel wanted to apply their their their
their work in presenting television away
from where they get it from but how they
share it there's certainly room for
innovation here but the basic business
of what they do which is taking things
off the air and putting them on the web
isn't going to happen anymore